KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
DID STEVE BANNON BETRAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
THE PRESIDENT WOULDN'T ANSWER
THE QUESTION EARLIER BUT HE
OFFERED THESE WORDS.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
HE CALLED ME A GREAT MAN LAST
NIGHT.
HE CHANGED HIS TUNE PRETTY
QUICK.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
I DON'T TALK TO HIM.
>> Dana: DESPITE YESTERDAY'S
PUBLIC LASHING FROM HIS FORMER
BOSS, BANNON ONLY HAD NICE WORDS
TO SAY LAST NIGHT.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS A GREAT MAN.
GOING TO THE COUNTRY, GIVING THE
SPEECHES.
I APPRECIATE THE KIND WORDS.
>> Dana: THE EX-CHIEF
STRATEGIST FACES THE THREAT FROM
THE
THE PRESIDENTS LAWYERS OVER
"DISPARAGING STATEMENTS AND
VIOLATING THE AGREEMENT NOT
TO --
HE HAS BEEN SENT A CEASE AND
DESIST LETTER.
SO HAS MICHAEL WOLFF, WHO
PUBLISHED BAM."
THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO STOP
THE BOOK FROM BEING RELEASED BUT
IT IS DUE OUT TOMORROW.
GERALDO, I THOUGHT I WOULD START
WITH YOU.
OR KIMBERLY.
AT THIS POINT THE BOOK IS COMING
OUT.
THERE'S REALLY NOTHING YOU CAN
DO LEGALLY, RIGHT?
>> Geraldo: YOU COULD DO A
CEASE AND DESIST LETTER.
I AM OPPOSED TO THEM.
THEY SHOW KIND OF A PANIC.
THEY BRING MORE ATTENTION THAN
THEY ARE INEFFECTIVE.
THERE IS A FIRST AMENDMENT IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO PUBLISH
AND THEN BE SUED.
IT'S OBVIOUS THERE ARE PLENTY OF
PROBLEMS WITH THE BOOK AS SEEN
THROUGH THE EYES OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT THEY, TRYING TO STOP IT
AHEAD OF TIME DOES NOTHING OTHER
THAN DRIVE SALES.
HE CRUSHED GAWKER.COM ON BEHALF
OF HULK HOGAN.
THAT'S REAL.
BUT WHY DRAW EVEN MORE ATTENTION
BUT WHY DRAW EVEN MORE ATTENTIO
ATTENTION?
WANT TO DO.
ALL IT'S DONE IS ACCELERATE THE
PUBLICATION.
>> Dana: WHEN YOU ARE DEALING
TRY TO IGNORE IT AND START A BIT
OF ATTENTION OR TRY TO
COUNTERPUNCH.
THE PRESIDENT'S STATEMENT WAS
STRONG YESTERDAY.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO WASTE MY
TIME OF THE COUNTRY TIME GOING
PAGE BY PAGE TALKING OUT OF BOOK
THAT'S COMPLETE FANTASY AND JUST
FULL OF TABLOID GOSSIP BECAUSE
IT'S SAD, PATHETIC.
THERE ARE PROBABLY MORE THAN 30
REQUESTS FOR ACCESS TO
INFORMATION FROM MICHAEL WOLFF
THAT WERE REPEATEDLY DENIED.
HE NEVER DISCUSSED THIS BOOK
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
WAS REPEATEDLY DENIED THAT, I
THINK BECAUSE WE SAW HIM FOR
WHAT HE WAS AND THERE WAS NO
REASON FOR US TO WASTE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
THE TIME.
>> Dana: SHE IS TRYING TO
CLEAN UP THE MESS SHE DIDN'T
>> Kimberly: THEY DECIDED TO
GIVE HIM ACCESS AND HE'S HAD
ACCESS.
TWO VERY HIGH PROFILE PEOPLE.
HE'S HAD THE ABILITY TO GET
THESE KIND OF INTERVIEWS AND GET
UNFETTERED ACCESS.
EARLY ON IN THE ADMINISTRATION,
PROBABLY NOT A VERY GOOD IDEA.
ILL-ADVISED BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO LET SOMEBODY BE EXPOSED
TO THE SHOP BEFORE STATE OPENS.
LIKE RESTAURANTS, THERE COULD BE
A LOT OF THINGS GOING ON.
WAIT UNTIL IT'S BAKED IN A BIT.
PAYING ATTENTION TO EVERYTHING,
QUITE CONVERSATIONAL.
HE SAW THE SEAN SPICER STUFF.
HE'S LISTENING AND ABSORBING THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THAT'S WHAT HE DOES.
IN A SITUATION LIKE THIS, IT'S
AT RISK FOR SOMEONE LIKE THIS
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY, A GOOD WRITER,
GOING TO WRITE THIS OUT.
THERE'S A LOT OF CONTENTION IN
TERMS OF THE ACCURACY OF IT BUT
HE SAYS HE HAS TAPES AS WELL.
PUBLISHERS ARE TRYING TO SELL
BOOKS.
BECAUSE OF ALL THE HYPE, ALL OF
THE NEWS COVERAGE YOU SEE ON
EVERY NETWORK ABOUT THIS, THEY
WANT TO CAPITALIZE IN A
FREE-MARKET SOCIETY, GET THE
SALES OUT.
>> Dana: THE P.R. NIGHTMARE
THAT A WHITE HOUSE MIGHT BE
GOING THROUGH, IT WILL END.
TWO OR THREE MORE DAYS OF THE
ON TO ANOTHER TOPIC.
>> Greg: THAT IS THE BEAUTY OF
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
THERE IS ALWAYS SOMETHING ON THE
HORIZON.
IT BLOWS YOUR MIND.
>> Kimberly: HE NEEDS TO DO A
MIKA TWEET IMMEDIATELY.
SO IT'S NEWS THAT IT'S CHAOS AND
DYSFUNCTIONAL WHEN
NONPOLITICIANS ACTUALLY MOVE
INTO THE POLITICAL REALM.
THIS GUYS THERE WITNESSING
GOVERNED WHO ARE LIKE THE
PEOPLE -- YEAH, YOU CAN SAY HE'S
WE BECAME PRESIDENT, MAYBE
EXCEPT FOR DANA, WE WOULD'VE HAD
A SIMILAR EXPERIENCE I THINK THE
BOOK'S MESSAGE -- YOU MADE A
GOOD POINT ABOUT THE WRITER.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT A PERFECT
WHITE HOUSE.
IT'S ABOUT A HUMAN WHITE HOUSE.
THESE ARE NOT BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE
FROM ASPEN OR HARVARD.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO CAN BARELY
SHAVE.
BANNON SHAVES HALF HIS FACE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE IGNORANT OF
YOU PUT STREET FIGHTERS IN THERE
FROM QUEENS AND ELSEWHERE.
NOMINATED A NEO-FIGHT OVER
HILLARY CLINTON, REMEMBER?
THEY DID IT FIRST WITH OBAMA.
LASTLY, YOU SAID WOLFF IS A GOOD
WRITER.
HE IS.
OBSERVATIONS AND CONCLUSIONS TO
HE WRITES AN ACTIVE VOICE.
BUT THE REPORTING IS IN THE
PASSIVE.
IT'S AS IF THINGS ARE HAPPENING
PART OF ME SAYS YEAH, A LOT OF
THIS COULD HAPPEN BUT IT'S LIKE
HE IS SHOVELING IT INTO A WAY
THAT FITS THE STORY.
>> Dana: FROM
USED A COPY EDIT.
>> Greg: THAT HIS RIVALRY.
THAT'S HER GOING I WISH I HAD
THAT BOOK.
AN AUTHOR THEY'RE DOCUMENTING
EVERYTHING.
THE TIME.
GREG WAS COMPLAINING ABOUT HIS
APARTMENT.
JESSE WAS A JERK.
JUAN WAS LATE.
>> Kimberly: GERALDO LOST HIS
SHIRT.
>> Jesse: DANA WAS JUDGING
EVERYBODY WITH HER EYES.
>> Kimberly: IS THIS A TRUE
STORY?
>> Jesse: THEY ALL SAY TRUMP
DIDN'T KNOW JIM     BOEHNER.
HE HAD BEEN LEAKING, >> Dana:
HE WAS ON THE RECORD.
WHEN HE WAS IN ALABAMA FOR THE
ROY MOORE EVENT ON STAGE ON LIVE
TELEVISION HE WAS BASICALLY
MAKING FUN OF IVANKA FOR SAYING
THERE IS SPECIAL PLACE IN HELL
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE ACCUSED --
NO LOVE LOST.
>> Jesse: THE DON JR. THING
AND JARED.
>> Kimberly: NOT FROM DAY ONE.
THIS WASN'T ANY KIND OF KUMBAYA
GARY COHN.
>> Dana: THE TEAM OF RIVALS
"DALLAS."
>> Dana: HELPED ME OUT,
GERALDO.
DON'T YOU AGREE WITH ME?
>> Geraldo: THIS NOTION WHERE
THEY MAKE AN OBSERVATION IS
THESE MEMORY AND EMOTIONAL
LAPSES AND HE'S NOT HIMSELF.
THIS IS SUCH BUNK.
I'M SORRY TO SAY, BUT THIS IS
COURTING PEOPLE WHO SPEND NO
TIME WITH THE PRESIDENT.
I DIDN'T SPEND ANY TIME WITH HIM
I'VE KNOWN HIM FOR 40 YEARS.
WE DID "THE
"CELEBRITY APPRENTICE""
TOGETHER.
HE IS AS SHARP AS EVER, AS
RELAXED AS EVER.
IN TERMS OF HIS PHYSICAL
INCENDIARY, IT'S VERY UNFAIR.
>> Jesse: TRUMP IS A FAST
RUNNER?
>> Greg: SAYING HE COULD
WANT.
THE PRESIDENT IS VERY
HARDWORKING.
HE CAMPAIGNED AS HARD AS ANYBODY
WHO RAN FOR THE PRESIDENT.
HE HAD NO FATIGUE IN THE
SITUATION.
HE WAS ALL IN, TRYING TO WIN.
WAY MORE THAN HILLARY CLINTON.
LET'S BE HONEST.
SHE WAS TRYING TO COLLECT
DOLLARS.
HE WAS TRYING TO COLLECT VOTES.
1:00 IN THE MORNING, HE WOULD
SHOW UP IN MICHIGAN AND MAKE
SURE HE MADE THOSE RALLIES.
EVERY TIME WE WERE AT ONE OF
THOSE CONVENTIONS OR DEBATES, HE
WAS OUT OF OLD TIME DOING THE
PRESS GAGGLE.
SAY WHAT YOU WANT, MAYBE IT'S
ACCURATE CRITICISM BUT DON'T
MISREPRESENT A LIE ABOUT THE
MAN'S ABILITY AND HIS STAMINA.
HE WANTED TO WIN.
I WANT TO CRUSH IT.
I WANT TO MAKE THE OTHER GUY CRY
FOR HIS MOM.
>> Greg: SOME OF THESE THINGS
COULD BE TRUE.
HE COULD EAT CHEESEBURGERS IN
BED.
THAT'S A PROBLEM?
>> Kimberly: WHO DOESN'T?
>> Greg: THAT'S HOW I WANT TO
GO.
LET'S SAY YOU LOOK AT SOME
THINGS AND YOU THINK THEY COULD
BE TRUE.
TEMPERAMENTAL, IMPULSIVE,
HE SAID IF A CANDIDATE OR A
PERSON CONNECTS WITH YOU ON ONE
BIG THING, THEN ALL THE LITTLE
THINGS BECOME LITTLE AND THEY
BECOME ACCEPTABLE.
I HAD A LOCKED OF PROBLEMS WITH
A LOT OF THINGS, MAINLY ABOUT
BEHAVIOR AND THINGS WE TALKED
ABOUT BUT THE BIG THING WHICH
WAS THE MESSAGE OVER NATIONAL
DOMESTIC SECURITY.
THE FACT THAT HE NAILED THAT
DOWN IN THE DISTANCE
FOLLOW-THROUGH ME ACCEPT THE
FACT THAT HE MIGHT SAY SOMETHING
THAT GOES OH, I CAN'T BELIEVE HE
SAID THAT BUT THE FACT IS IF YOU
GET THE BIG THING RIGHT, THE